hey there I will be the dark arts tour
coming to West Siloam Springs Oklahoma
at Cherokee Casino that's June 9th June
15th and 16th Yuk Yuk's Calgary Calgary
Alberta and this in Canada our friends
our northern friends 23rd of June
temblor brewing Bakersfield California
and Bakersfield boy anything can happen
out there you might go missing
you might start a family you might find
gold baby dust Baker's field July sixth
through eighth levity live and that's in
Oxnard California July 20th through 22nd
charlie good nights Raleigh North
Carolina
August 16th through 18th the Laugh
Factory in Chicago Illinois you've been
asking and I'm excited to come back
there to the state that my mother was
born in August 23rd to August 25 helium
comedy club in Buffalo New York and if
they don't have the tickets up for sale
then hit them up and act some why
September 14th and 15th that's Zanies in
Nashville Tennessee some more dates will
be added and and I'm just grateful to be
getting out there and having people come
man it's going to be fun we're gonna do
some cool stuff we're also going to
start doing some outreach where we're
going to do some things for single moms
in some of these cities so whenever we
go into a city and do a show or a
weekend of shows we're gonna have people
in advance listeners can submit single
mothers that they know and and we're
gonna we're gonna get the mother a
babysitter her babysitter you know so
she has somebody that she trusts and
we're gonna you know take care of her
and a friend take them out to dinner and
then get them a nice setup at the show
you know nice second hour third row seat
and just make it so a nice single mom
can come out and enjoy an evening and
know that her children are being taken
care of I think that's going to be
really really cool and I want to thank
our patreon supporters because that's
what our patreon money is is going to
start going towards is paying for things
like that so really excited about that
and
this man it's gonna be cool this is so
cool it's like a fun there's gonna be a
fun fall we're also going to do one
other show in rural Illinois and it's a
fundraiser for the Paramount Theater and
that's in Wyoming Illinois those dates
will be up this week as well and that's
going to be June 29 to Friday 6 p.m. and
8 p.m. that's in Stark County Illinois
and that's middle-of-nowhere boy and and
that's where I'm from not there
originally
but I'm from middle of nowhere just a
different one down in Louisiana this
episode as always is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block 18:11 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles they got that
food and they got that feeling and all
you need is your face great block pizza
get that hitter dude I hate to use this
music again to start off our show but I
also love to use it again and this is
shine by Bishop Gunn
[Music]
I just needed this today
come on now I'm just sitting on your
front porch wandering how could I be so
far from my home and my mind is
somewhere else but when I founded our
patch up where it's been now I'm just
floating on the breeze and I feel
hopeful and like these leaves that must
be must be cursed feel it baby feel em
[Music]
on now
come on
[Music]
singing just and that is shine by Bishop
Gunn offer the new album Natchez and
that's out of Natchez Mississippi and I
used to work my a lot of you guys
already know it I'll say it one more
time one of my one of my good friends
who passed away died of addiction and
and he used to he employed me to work on
his farm for a few years and I became
good friends with his family right after
college and one of his sons is now the
drummer in that beautiful band called
Bishop Gunn and that's their single
that's hitting the airwaves man it's
called shine and and yeah that just you
know it makes me feel good when I hear
that song and so I had to start off with
that thank you think thanks for coming
in and welcome to you whoever you are
whoever you're if you're listening you
got your ears open and and you're
sharing a moment of your time with me
man I you know I I uh what's going on a
lot of stuff is going on
you know we had you know I got to go on
Joe Rogan this week we went on Joe Rogan
and Joe Rogan's you know it's I was
nervous first of all you know I was
nervous because I look up to Joe so much
you know and for some reason with me I
think when I look up to somebody it for
some reason it makes me kind of nervous
you know I guess well you wanna I don't
know it's like when you're hanging out
you know what it feels like to me a
little bit it's like you're hanging out
with your big brother and his friends
and you're like you wanna you know
you're just I don't know I was just
nervous but it was it was wild and right
off the bat Joe Joe starts talking to me
and I love Joe you know I'm extremely
grateful to him you know he's done a lot
of nice things small things that were
really nice for me like out of like he
would just see me do comedy and I've
said this before but he would just drop
me a text a couple days later than
today and just say hey man you had a
really good set you know and uh and that
kind of stuff like you don't realize
sometimes like somebody that you had my
or like you know telling you something
pop sharing something positive
supporting what you do you don't realize
how much that means to that person and
he doesn't you know I don't think he you
know he doesn't probably realize it but
it's like I would get those texts and
I'm like wow man you know it's like your
big bro it's like I don't know it's just
like you're it's like impressing your
brother impressing I don't know you know
and that kind of stuff really just rez
has resonated with me over the years
he's done that and Joey Diaz does that
as well he'll call you but but Joe would
do that sometimes and just hit me up and
say hey man you were really funny last
night and you know coming from you know
my life when all I wanted to do probably
was you know make make people I admired
you know make them feel like or make
them feel like I was part of like I was
okay you know maybe some of that goes
back to like father and brother you know
not being present growing up and all of
that but you know just when you have a
you know when you have a male figure in
it you know just that support support
that's really what it is Joe's been so
supportive and so you know anyway but
you know I was excited to be in there
and I was excited to get to hang out
with him because he thinks like wild you
know he's like he thinks like he's got
you know it's like I don't I think he
has more than one brain in his head you
know Joe Rogan might have five or six
brains in there and one of the brains is
probably a rat you know and then he's
but he might have other brains orbiting
around brains you know he might have one
brains it's you know he might have
brains in the distance you know cooking
elk I mean he's got you know he just he
continues to kind of like expand his way
of thinking and so right in the
beginning he was talking about infinite
and infinite uh if there were infinite
universes
and if there were more than just one of
you and I couldn't even I was so nervous
kind of I was just couldn't even think
really that good and but then now I'm
thinking after that I texted him the
next day and I was like mana
I'm obsessed now with wondering if there
are infinite universes so many so this
is what he was saying there's so many
infinite universes that if you there
would be a possibility for you to meet
your exact self like you know say the
two universes get close enough to each
other somehow in orbits or whatever and
then you you know there's you know
programs you're both astronauts or
something you meet like if you were to
able to meet your exact self think about
that if you were able to meet your exact
self and I was just like I left there
thinking what I like myself like
if I can find met me like what I like me
what would I do what would I think what
I think I was neat you know what I think
I was tall what I think that I was
handsome you know what I think that I I
mean would I know if I were able to look
into my own eyes would I be able to like
see my truth set like another like
another dimension you know especially
since most of my life you know
especially growing up like I didn't have
any a lot of self-worth so I was most of
my self-worth would come from what other
people thought of me you know there was
no you know the there was nothing inside
of me so everything that I knew I had to
get from the outside and so I was so
hyper aware of what other people were
constantly thinking because I needed to
be because I needed that next second and
that next minute and that next you know
just to know I knew I was monitoring how
I was and if I was okay through moment
to moment interaction with others and
what they would give me back that's how
I feel about myself I was thinking like
if if I based my feelings off of what
other people thought of me and I saw
myself would I then like looking into my
own eyes would I be able to you know
just come full circle with with what
self worth means and what it you know
and just I get to another plateau in
thinking about that but ever just
fascinated me I left out of there
thinking like what the [ __ ] I never
thought about running into myself what I
think I had bad breath you know what I
think I had like a longneck or a regular
neck room you know what kind of us you
know a four out of ten kind of a
mid-range lower you know lower mid-range
neck medium rare
because I've all you know I've had you
know my don't have a super long neck and
I don't think a lot of people my family
we're not real look around us some
people have a long neck you know when
you see those people they're looking for
stuff and they can you know look behind
the sofa easier and they don't lose
their wallet probably as much because
they
you know they got that extra two inches
to look then the gays you know they
could see fruit easier if they reach if
they're looking for fruits but when you
have that limited neck man you kind of
you know you're stuck on your own little
bitty you know it's not really a hilltop
you just kind of stuck on you know you
kind of just hanging out on your own
cliffside you can't do a lot when you
got that limited kind of that limited
net and I come from a long line of
people with limited necks but yeah I was
just wondering if you saw yourself and
you looked in your own eyes would you I
don't know what we thought me would
you're just whole world explode like
would you just know everything what I
like myself what I like I just blew my
mind
if there were infinite universes and it
just blew my mind man so I left out of
there I think with a little bit more
thinking you know and I think that
that's kind of what Joe Rogan does for
me is he makes me think a little bit
more and he makes me think sometimes I'm
uncomfortable things you know he makes
me think outside of like the confines of
the comfortable confines of things that
you know these these templates that I
was raised in I raised around or just
that I saw you know it's kind of like
when you see remember when you got that
you got them colors when you were a
child and your mother took you to the
color shop and you got that a box you
got that box eight hitters you know that
were that you know just that little
[ __ ] that ROYGBIV fiasco you know you
got that little eight pack that 8-ball
you know you got that eight ball and
suddenly some dude shows up with that
six that follow up box and your [ __ ]
dick blew out of your ears remember that
dude I remember my nuts traveled up my
body and looked out of my I hose because
I was just I was just shook by the fact
that some man suddenly had 56 more
colors than I had some boy I mean not a
man they didn't have any men
class you know in disguise or anything
but that some boy it blew my mind and
suddenly you were doing different
pictures and you were thinking different
things and you you were like [ __ ]
magenta I'm out here on magenta and then
and then and then everything changed
because then I would see a you know
maybe I would see a somebody's shirt or
hat or a you know I would see a woman's
head at church and be like oh that's a
magenta hat and suddenly you know you
have more elements to put out into your
template to put out into your world and
that's kind of I think you know that's
kind of what I left out of Joe Rogan's
podcast thinking I left out of their
actually just thinking you know he makes
me think and I think he makes a lot of
you know young men and women think you
know he's kind of this dope-ass
outerspace male you know marine kind of
not he's just everything I don't know
what he is man it's almost like if you
took a whole timeline of existence and
just took it like that and put it all in
no one person it's like the past and you
know in the future and everything and
he's probably got moons
I bet dude I bet he has moons going
around him I bet there's a moon way off
in the distance that we don't even know
about that's just that you know just
that rogen that Rogen moon but it was an
honor man it's an honor to go in there
you know it's just an honor you know
like uh I don't know it made and it made
me fit you know I just felt like
accepted you know like he made me feel
accepted which for me is like a really
big thing you know like um you know like
I think a lot of my life I don't feel
that way um and so to go in and and I
don't I don't even think these are
things that he's you know outwardly
doing like on purpose I think someone's
just his nature
you know I think in some ways he's like
a little bit of like that big brother
that like you know you know I had my
brother but my brother you know didn't
live with us and like you know and he
you know and he's had some you know tell
he's had some tough times even though
I'll you know I really love my brother
and I'm you know I don't think I've ever
been prouder I think you buddy give my
whole life than him but uh anyway damn
boy
this [ __ ] got me glee can out my
eyeballs dude you know I'm saying I'm
[ __ ] making salt water dude I'm a
damn I'm like a sixth grade science
experiments it but yeah I don't know he
just made me feel accepted and just you
know I don't know but I'm just grateful
man it you know I'm just grateful to be
in an environment where I feel inspired
you know I get to go on some of these
other podcast fighter and the kid and
those guys make me laugh man you know
this and they make you laugh I know it
because I get out on the road and I see
these you know I see a fighter and the
kid listeners and I'm a fighter in the
kid listener so I know it's like there's
just this wild we're part of their party
you know we're part of their party and I
guess I'm just grateful to Bisbee you
know just just I guess I don't know I'm
just grateful I guess to feel accepted
so and maybe you know that shouldn't
matter to me and I don't I don't know if
it matters it's not a thing like it like
I walk around thinking like those guys
didn't accept me ever but
I don't know I just and it's just
something that I feel so anyway man
there was a lot more to spend in time
over at Rogen's and it you know the
conversation was kind of all over and he
thinks it's so fast and it's hard for me
to you know he's got that he's got Lance
Armstrong in his blood so that dudes out
there he's in outer space he's walking
on the moon
you know he's juggling he's playing
saxophone I mean he's got all kinds of
things and going on inside of him and
but it was fun man it was exciting and
it was fun and so if you wonder what
it's like to kind of go in because I get
a lot of messages I could deal what's it
like to go to Joe Rogan's and you know
is it like is it underground somebody
asked me if it's underground like it's a
bunker and that made me laugh so hard
man
no actually it's in a blimp it is we
leave the earth and we go out there and
Eddie Bravo's the driver and we just
travel around and so that way you get a
first-hand look at some of the things
that um you know some of the you know
some of the things that Joe is talking
about but yeah man I just had a blast
and I and I know that a lot of you know
people that are you know fans of mine
and friends of mine and just being able
to listen to me talk to somebody that we
all admire like Joe I just know it was
fun for a lot of us so I was just glad
to be I was just glad to be there what
else um what else is going on sorry dude
I got on these you know I started
dripping out the face you know so this
happens whatever that's life dude that's
life well whatever was inside me I'm
glad it's not in me anymore bro get out
you know get out of me if you got to
come out my eyes you must be something
wild that's what I think about you know
emotions and stuff cuz there's a lot of
ways to get out of my body you know you
can come out my ass come out my mouth
ears but if you there must be something
there must be something special about
emotions if the way that they have to
get out of your body is they have to
call out of your eyes via
water and salt which are the two which I
think look bottom line water salt
sunlight that's what that's what it all
is out here that's what we all that's
the bottom line if you crack me open
with a baseball bat or for a couple of
Vietnamese dude to kick me open that I
bet that at the end of it all that you
break me all the way down I'm just water
and salt and sunlight that we all are
but that must be something must be
something special about emotion if the
way that it gets out of you think about
to give pores all over your body
whatever those feelings are when you
feel something and in it emotes out of
your eyeballs via salt water I mean
that's the dark arts right there is a
beautiful dark art but not dying that is
a dark art think I'm thinking it has to
core dude it could come out of any of
your pores ears eyes but wiener what if
you cried out of your wiener imagine
that dude imagine there's some kid he's
just all pissed and his dad's about to
come whoop him cuz he stole something
you know maybe he stole a couple of you
know extra you know cuts a cabbage or
something they were doing cabbage soup
and he snuck up by the cutting board and
just grabbed two little cuts of cabbage
and ran off to his room and just [ __ ]
you know rabbit face those [ __ ] into
his belly and now his daddy's pissed and
he knows his daddy's about to poop him
and he's just sitting there and he's got
a cry but how it he does it he just
breaks his wiener out him just straight
up just just tears up right out into a
beautiful stream just a beautiful stream
of sadness flying out of his wiener
right out the window I mean could you
imagine but that's not how it works you
don't feel sad and then you know and
then tears come out of your butt that's
not how it works there's something that
happens in Saudi when you feel something
emotional where it climbs up out of your
chest through your throat
and comes out Joe [ __ ] the potholes
to your soul baby it's pretty powerful
man it's powerful stuff so and I know I
get into my feelings sometimes dude I
just didn't have him a lot growing up
and I think I'm just kind of grateful to
have some of them now but thank you guys
so much for being here with man and
thanks for anybody that checked out the
you know being on there with Joe Rogan
man I just can't you know it's just fun
I just you know I just
man just was fun dude it's fun you go in
there and they got this scary um they
got like a Mountain Cat I don't know
what they killed dude but he kills
everything you know he could kill I mean
dude I wouldn't be surprised honestly
dude I looked at him in the eyes at one
point and I asked him you know I'm gonna
fast if he'd been out of space or if he
you know what if he knows oh if the
government tried to get to him and he
said no to me and I believed him but
I'll you know I wouldn't be surprised if
he has like a shuttle or something dude
he could be out there hunting [ __ ]
space bears would you be shocked would
you be shocked if Rogan stood up in a
damn space bear fur coat I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be man he's uh I wouldn't be at
all and if we got to Impe we got to send
anybody in the space to do it I'd send
him I'd send him a hundred percent you
know he's kind of like the leader but
anyhow man yeah I just I don't know why
I'm just kind of rambling on that I
guess it's just on my mind and heart and
then a lot of people were asking me yeah
and it's like ah but the best was is it
underground that was the best the best
thing I've heard so thank you to whoever
sent that in to me today's episode is
brought to you by Ridge wallet and Ridge
wallet is you know a lot of times you
see a man and you see there but you know
and a woman too and some time I hearty
lesbian they want to roll like this and
you see there but but you also see some
on there but you're like what is that on
there but you know it's like their butt
has just like some on it and that's a
wallet that's in their pants but it's
it's much weird
you know and so now you got the new
Ridge wallet and that's that front
pocket carry and this that beautiful
hitter and the thing is is you put your
stuff in here and you carry it with you
you don't have to be this big old
Galapagos turtle living on your ass
cheek like you used to with that old
wallet
dude you're all we think about what's in
your wallet you know you got that
picture your girl used to you know bust
down on back in the day 8th grade you
got headshots you know you got Olin
Mills picture what the [ __ ] are you
doing you got them condoms you never use
bra and you're married now you've been
married for a decade get rid of that
junk get rid of that old specimen that
old petri dish you carrying around that
thing smells smell your wallet come on
so now you get that new front pocket
carry that's Ridge wallet calm /co it's
10% off look man go check it out and I
didn't like mine at first I'll be honest
with you first three days I was like
since then all 58 days since then
complete savagery bra enjoying my life
being in my front pocket carry bra
what's in your carry I'm gonna remind
you to check out my West Coast buds
that's a new podcast and that's by Joe
DeMaio and Joe is um he's kind of a
connoisseur he's like an everyday man
sort of connoisseur he likes cannabis
coffee
he likes comedy and he likes spirits and
I'm not talking ghosts you know I'm
talking about alcohol you know he likes
unless a [ __ ] Grim Reaper shows up
with a shot of gin then maybe he likes
it all and he is on a unique character
and he owns a dispensary in Tigard
Oregon called Coral Cove and Joe will
talk to you about everything that he
goes through up there and what it's like
making whiskey making jokes a lot of
how-to it's kind of an inside baseball
look at those industries selling dope
doing all of that so check it out we'll
have the link below and that's my West
Coast buds what else is going on man
let's get into some other things I'll
tell you about something my uh oh
they had that school shooting I know
people are like thinking about it but I
you know I was thinking about more like
you know and god bless everybody and you
know that you know if you have a family
member
anything that's you know how to deal
with that or any of these it's becoming
such a commonplace thing and I was
talking to one of my one of our
producers Nick earlier and he and Nick's
a beautiful young man he might have been
a premature baby but you know that's you
know he couldn't and I don't honestly I
don't know if you ever shake being a
premature baby but I think he's mastered
as well as any man could he say you know
handsome young felon anyhow what
happened up I was talking to him and he
was saying whoa
you know once something happened because
it's like why does this keep happening
and why does this keep happening and in
one of the things is once something
happens to the first time then it
happens more like and the more I think
about it like yes I think it has a great
deal to do with mental health you know
yes I think that that these high-profile
hot you know fast action assault rifles
and [ __ ] I think that I can't I don't
know if we need those I've never seen a
hunter have like 1,100 deer running at
him you know with pistols on their hoof
you know like you know you don't have 70
raccoons you know coming down on on
parachutes you know you don't have any
you know on them raccoon of shoots just
dropping down and you got to mow em all
out we don't have that so it's like do
we need that you know I go back to the
old days so you got a load you got a
load and show and that seems more if you
know that seems more fair but you know
he was but anyway our producer Nick I
was talking him he was saying you know I
think it's because once it happens once
then other people see it and kids know
do what what they went out what caused
the most harm I guess a sick child will
a sick anyone will think that way you
know I think it didn't hurt you didn't
see it a lot in the past because it
wasn't it hadn't been done yet
you know you don't see somebody learn to
juggle or try juggling until somebody
else you know been working with magic
balls in the air and it once it's done
that first time then you see more of it
and so that's I think that has a lot to
do with it why does this keep happening
because it's happened once and people
see the effect and they see you know you
have a kid that's probably somewhere
inside of himself as mentally broken or
so broken and he just you know in the
devil gets him and he wants to do bad
and he wants to you know he he doesn't
see any difference in making other
people outside of him feel the pain that
he feels inside of himself he can't
differentiate between if that's okay or
if that's not okay or maybe he just
thinks it is it is okay you know I maybe
he thinks huh or I heard so bad that
everyone should hurt and so he bust down
like that but yeah you know do we do I
don't think we need these hop hop hop
hop our weapons what or also how about
that little liaison period from when you
want the weapon and when you get the
weapon
how about that let's give a little more
time look there's no reason that I need
look I need a passport sometimes
immediately I get that you need that
passport within three days you got a
surprise trip you leaving but I can't
think of a super good reason that I need
an ar-15 by Thursday can't think of one
and if I do have a reason
there's nothing logical as to why that
couldn't wait another week so it's just
I mean it's just horrific and it's
tragic and you know young people are
mimics and they they do what they see
you know they little monkeys young
people are little monkeys and they do
what they see and so I didn't mean to
bring it down by talking about that
stuff but I know down there in Texas
some we have a lot of listeners in Texas
or nah and you know in Texas was one of
my favorite states I mean Texas is a
kind of state where you show up and you
do your work and you live your life and
you show respect and other people show
respect and that's how life is and I've
always loved Texas and it's just a
tragedy to see some of this kind of
stuff just continue to happen but I've
said before we should have classes there
should be a class I don't give a [ __ ]
about social studies I don't give a [ __ ]
about spelling there should be classes
in school where you learn to express
your feelings and let other people
express their feelings and how you work
together on that
and how you can just know if you are
talking to a friend if if if they're
okay or not or how if you're not okay
you could try to share some of that [ __ ]
man on I know sound you know some of
this stuff might sound like weakness and
everything but I don't think it is I
think it's the toughest thing you can do
is you know teach young people how to be
vulnerable and and help us and help them
learn because [ __ ] dude I feel I got to
do this I'm doing I'm in these programs
now and I'm doing this [ __ ] now and I'm
38 bro I'm a straight up a dolt you know
you want to catch me in 40 40 years bro
you can catch
in the G yard son I'll be six feet down
a couple brothers throwing dirt on me
shoveling out you know I'll be trying to
crawl through the dirt just bones only
trying to catch a little bit of you know
a little bit of marrow out of something
maybe sweet gal that's about you know a
couple plots over cuz you know I'm gonna
be that dark artist when I'm in the dirt
and I'm saying just cuz I'm in the grave
doesn't mean I'm not gonna be um you
know trying to get out there and get a
little bit of Cossacks or a little bit
of um you know tail bone or not tail
bone but um is there any bones in the
vagina you know what I'm saying
I don't think vagina bone but it is it I
don't know dude I think I felt a bone
down there something before not like uh
but you know I think there's what's
holding the vagina up some kind of bone
whatever that is boy you know I'll be
you know I'll be you know peeking out of
ant farms and stuff once I'm buried I'm
not done and I'm not gonna be a ghost
boy maybe that underground rattler you
know I'm gonna be down there just
sifting through sand face-first can you
believe that's the most gangster thing
about snakes dude they go face-fucking
first through the dirt what dude I lose
my [ __ ] if I walk into a cobweb snake a
snake do face first forever wherever
they go
can you Amanda sand you know that and I
know some people like them and stuff
like that but every now and then a snake
shakes I choke a snake chokes out an old
lady in Tucson
you know that's once a month a snake
will put a senior citizen into a hard
scarf a snake will just drop that hard
scarf on a senior citizen and next thing
you know they wake up in heaven so a
snake is a very dangerous animal
what else what else is going on man I'm
still on Paleo diet and dude it's
getting easier it's getting easier and I
feel better and you know I talked about
it last week but I don't have anybody
gasp did I did I could count on two
fingers the number of times that I've
had body gas and that's been truly
beautiful
because look dude I've been you know
I've had I had gas for years to be
honest with you probably most of my life
and it's fun I get it sometimes you know
changing the whole environment of a room
with a secret weapon is exciting I'm not
gonna say that [ __ ] is an exciting dude
it's like having David Blaine [ __ ]
pop up out of your butt suddenly
everybody doesn't know what the hell
stinks or who did it it's like Agatha
Christie is straight-up living in your
[ __ ] bro that's straight up that
that's that is I mean us as beautiful
making mysteries like that
just making air mysteries but but it's
uh it's nice to not have that it's nice
to not be chatting with somebody and you
can't even think because did it a
certain point uh and this is I know this
probably a little grotesque and below
some people's education level and if it
is then [ __ ] take a hike because I'm
smart too
but maybe I'm just not talking about you
know you know glacier melt right now
maybe I'm not talking about you know
birds how long birds beaks are or the
Nasdaq maybe I'm just talking a regular
life but it's crazy I noticed this for
me if I when I used to have body gas a
lot if I had you're in your stomach a
fart
we'll call it a fart because I don't
know if they have a better term for it
yet but a fart whilst it almost starts
to develop a brain a little bit cuz
you're like damn this thing it's like
thinking because you got it you got it
nobody knows you got it and it starts to
know it got you at some point when it
gets close to that cliff it starts to
know that it's in control and you start
to feel it think a little bit does
anybody know I'm talking about I'm
talking about fart think and I think
that's a real condition I think it's a
real condition for the future what else
is happening man what else can we talk
about oh look man a lot of things a lot
of things have happened we had a lot of
beautiful voicemails that came in and
I'm gonna get to those some of those
we'll go through them we'll keep talking
about other stuff you know it's it was
just a crazy week you know getting to go
in and talk with Joe and just you know
just be around somebody that I just look
up to and then I watch on stage and that
you know he inspires me to be fearless
and to say what I think especially in
Hollywood you know this place doesn't
want you saying what you think you know
I mean it's like you know sometimes I
mean I'm happy to be here and I want to
work in this industry but it's you know
it's crazy to me I mean yeah I just even
look at like how Hollywood is suddenly
like you know and I arm suddenly it's
like so it's all about diversity you
know but two years ago black people had
to beg to be on the Academy Awards you
know and that's not the kind of did just
I don't know
don't trust this industry sometimes and
maybe that's just business and I need to
ball up a little bit and that's fine
look I'm out here to learn I don't know
I'm out here to learn let's take this
call that came in about their weekend
you know every every week you can call
them leave a voicemail on the hotline
the hotline is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and that
hotline mostly has all types of things
people calling and look there's their I
can't even tell you how many calls we
get a lot and that doesn't mean that we
don't care it's just hard to sometimes
get back to all of them some of them are
people you know you're going off and you
know there's a couple of voicemails
people [ __ ] couples and men only and
everything happening people some ladies
training I don't want to say parakeets
but it sounds like parakeets or she has
a you know twins with like real
high-pitched voices or something that
are if they're eating seed or something
it sounds hella sketchy bruh but um but
yeah there's a lot of stuff on there
it's just not even real stuff but we go
through it all you know in some things
we can get to in some things we can't if
you callin left a voicemail don't feel
bad it's not a rejection it's just you
know right now it didn't fit in the
episode or or maybe we'll do it in the
future or maybe call back at some other
time but thank you for everybody that's
called or texted we don't want to do oh
I want to play every week you can call
let me know if you want if you had a
great weekend or a bad weekend let us
know how it was and each each will play
some every week and we'll put a contest
winner at the end of each month for this
past week and how it was great bad
whatever here's a weekend story that
came in right here
hey what's up Co I'm a college student
I'm studying biology and I've been
supporting myself by working a third
shift at a gas station kind of in the
ghetto of the city but colleges dang
dude good luck man that sounds like a
place where people get murdered a lot no
offense and I hope you'd you know and I
hope everything's good with you
especially since you're still in college
biology man that biology was crazy dude
remember biology you didn't know
anything next thing you know you're
cutting into a frog you know I'm saying
next thing you're running around with a
frog
on your fingertips and showing it to the
ladies every answer in biology
mitochondria that was the answer on
every test every it was all mitochondria
sometimes it was a cytoplasm boom if you
are in seventh grade and you are still
looking for answers that's the answer to
everyone thank you for calling young a
young brother homeward and it's usually
alright but uh last night uh six guys
came in and they just bought a gas can
and put like two gallons of gasoline and
they seemed really calm real children oh
and that's sketchy man when you show up
and you just get that gas can gas only
that means you're out of out of gas or
that's arson and a lot of times when
arson happens you know that's either
insurance money or somebody has like a
sleep and family member or something and
he's about to change the game and they
bout to you know really just change it
all and maybe end up on Dateline let's
hear more they came back like two hours
later just high as [ __ ] probably on
method freaking out
probably on method were probably on gas
dude I remember on Halloween one time we
ate some mushrooms you know some of them
beautiful little [ __ ] land creatures
and we one of my buddies Todd tried to
drink some gasoline and had to go
actually to the I guess it went to the
emergency room but let's hear more
they're tired trying to return the gas
can because there's like 12 bucks but uh
the store policy is a contra third gas
cans was just a gas and so they were
like yelling at me and talking all at
once and they were gonna stab me if I
didn't cut my head off and [ __ ] damn cut
your head off bro that's a Greyhound bus
move bro that's a finishing move on the
Greyhound bus version of MORTAL KOMBAT
and I don't know what the cheat code is
to open that up but let's hear more you
know I was a Marine out of high school
so I'm not afraid of any man but you
know six makes me really concerned
December father you hear that confidence
in that man's voice right there dude
that's the kind of stuff that I wish I
had man just hearing you say that I'm a
marine so I'm not worried about any man
but six of them make me concerned that's
gangster dude that's awesome man thanks
to your service I got to you know I was
fortunate enough to get to go do some
tours um of just as a comedian and we
went to you know I think I maybe did
five or six you know trips overseas and
and you go on those bases boy and look
Navy does their thing Air Force does
their thing army does their thing but
when the Marines show up they go they go
first Marines go first man and it's just
you know impressive group let's hear
more bro this this sounds like it's not
going well brothers do want that $12
back I mean you got that policy let's
hear more no gas once you got gas in the
can that's yo can end up yelling for the
gas can for a little bit more and they
bought like $400 a random gas station
food [ __ ] and like a lot of lottery
tickets what times they didn't believe
it on their own Oh a lottery ticket Zess
I mean yeah if you're huffing gas bro
you'll definitely you know you'll take a
chance to win half a mil do by just
scratching on something because if
you're huffing gas you use used to
scratching your skin you should have
scratch you'll scratch your own chest
hair off you know you'll have this with
a little you know kind of bloody ball of
fur and hair and skin but um so yeah
lottery tickets I mean that's a
methamphetamine that's you know that's
that's that's everything that's a that's
a that's a full-time job for a
methamphetamine addict because they got
the itch in them naturally and now
they're putting it to work for that
chance at um you know fifty thousand
dollars paid over a hundred weeks let's
hear more spent like four hundred five
hundred bucks on them unless told me I
was a [ __ ] yeah there was my weekend
they left and told you you were a [ __ ]
that's hilarious bro well look man I
come in do you do working in the hot you
know in a tough neighborhood and they
get I mean I don't know if it's together
you said it's a shady neighborhood but I
come in do you do cuz that's that's a
tough area a lot of times people out
there you know eating honey buns and
drink
[ __ ] diesel you know you get a couple
of you know young soldiers hopped up on
some 91 octane you know and next thing
you know they want a [ __ ] fistfight
and you just trying to mop you know
you're just trying to [ __ ] you know
you could just had a give up you know
you got a brain you just had a brain
freeze because you and your ninth
slushie and you back their brain
freezing trying to [ __ ] push that hot
mop around and these Muppets are
straight-up they come in all jaw it up
you don't want them just lit a cigarette
forgot he's drinking gas and now he's
you know now he's one of the Flaming
Lips and [ __ ] gets Fiasco time and
everybody wants Fritos
dude it's savage out there man and I
commend you for working on the front
lines that's the front lines of American
war right there the man that's working
overnight trying to make it through
school trying to learn about biology and
just fending off straight [ __ ] night
Muppets trying to get that $12 back Gang
Gang baby take care of yourself out
there thanks for calling I appreciate
that man
I remember I never work at a gas station
know one time my buddy got sick and he
worked at a gas station and he's like
dude I need you to take my shift and I'd
never work there and I went and uh and I
did it man you know I think I stole
about there how about $30 did and I
stole all moved so many Otis Spunkmeyer
cookies dude I [ __ ] was sick in the
morning dude come sunrise I was sick to
my stomach but uh but that was fun you
know those are the good old days let's
take another call man what do we got
here onward hi this is Ellen Cullinan
from Virginia Beach and this is some
advice for Nicole who's dealing with an
alcoholic boyfriend oh yeah we had these
are we got a response from last week's
call this is for Nicole dealing with an
alcoholic boyfriend she called at the
end of last week's episode my name is
Nicole I'm 34 my boyfriend is 40 and
he's struggling really hard with
alcoholism let's hear more thanks for
calling Ellen Nicole you're in a
life-or-death situation right now and
this is what you need to do you need to
get on the phone and you need to find a
place where you can take your boyfriend
where he can go through a medical detox
if he tries to do it by his self he can
have seizures
he can die from alcohol poisoning he
cannot do this alone
he needs a medical professional and with
that being said he also needs to get to
an AAA meeting as soon as possible there
are inner group members all over the
country that you can call and there are
also apps where you can find the closest
meeting to you have them get a sponsor
have them get the big book having do 90
meetings in 90 days and get serious get
committed about your future your future
with him if you still think that there
is one let me tell you something I speak
from experience I was living in Las
Vegas from us three years
oh that sounds helis right there boy Las
Vegas do that anything could happen out
there you know you put it all on the
table
you know they got women wearing those
hats with the feathers on them you can
get [ __ ] you know you like peacocks
trying to [ __ ] you because they think
you know as false advertising you're
running around with on your dome they
got escorts cocaine bra and the cocaine
is good because there's no humidity in
the air cocaine will keep let me tell
you that that [ __ ] will keep out on a
counter as long as the humidity is down
and you keep the air conditioner off and
no ceiling fans boy great way to into
cocaine party is somebody just [ __ ]
flipping on the fan switch but but let's
hear a little more advice thank you for
calling in about this Ellen three years
with a fighter pilot he was also a Coker
professional and I had to leave I left
their relationship was the hardest thing
I've ever done in my life to the day I
still cry about it but I look back on it
now and I just think about where would I
have been if I just stayed with him and
that's the truth you know you got to
think about yourself long-term there you
know she's calling with Laura has some
issues last week and look I you know
Ellen owner you're telling her you need
to get this you know your man to a
meeting and you need to get him to a
professional he needs to get himself you
know and I'm not discrediting what
you're saying these are these are all
great suggestions Ellen you know
especially from a woman that's been
there but here yeah he needs to get
himself and she needs to get herself
some help you know she needs to get to
some al-anon meetings or she needs to
get to she needs to get in a better
I swear you know there's codependency
meetings and these are suggestions look
I'm not a lady you know I never had a
man that you know loved me and we just
also maybe took advantage of my love
because he wanted to do dope and not
take care of himself I never had that
but you know but I know that you can't
you know people will have to want to
help themselves and that you can only
help so much and when when when Nicole
called in she sounded really at her wits
in so but look you heard her from
another lady
Nicole you got to start taking care of
yourself and get that man in the detox
and he needs to take care of himself
because if one of y'all ain't taking
care of yourselves
then what y'all gonna do neither one of
y'all is taking care of yourselves you
both gonna figure it out [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that I'll be honest with you because
look I'll tell you what happened I saw
two mentally challenged people making
out one time at a stoplight out outdoors
not in the vehicle and I and I called
the police
and I feel I regret it sometimes but I
could tell man I've spent time dude we
know one of my best friends growing up
had Down syndrome I've spent time around
you know I've spent people that are
mentally lit you know some of God's
favorites I've been around and they will
someone will [ __ ] someone want a party
they're just like us you know they got
that limbic system just like us they got
you know the dirty dark arts just
dangling off the you know the base of
their spine in the base of their brain
that you know that little brainstem at
things lit up with just you know
eggplant emojis and uh you know little
umbrellas with semen emojis hitting the
top of them and so they want a party
just like us and I knew I could tell
that these two at this stoplight we're
gonna they were gonna they were thinking
about sex
and and so I called the police and the
lady said well what's what is what why
what is this about and I said well if
those two people make a child that child
the chances of that child being
comfortable and well in its own skin
probably not super great and I know
that's me jumping to conclusions that
might be me playing a little bit of you
know moderator in the universe but it's
just like if they can't help themselves
if they not in a place where they can be
super well themselves then they can only
do so much together those two people at
that stoplight and they can kiss and hug
and pleasure each other and that kind of
thing but when it comes to we're gonna
start something new together we're gonna
start a small business or we're gonna
make a child I don't know I don't know
if that's the best move and that's for
this where I kind of where I see you at
a little bit Laura and and Thank You
Ellen for calling in and giving some
suggestions to her we also this is the
first time we've ever had it we have a
video call that came in and this is um
this is on live raise and the link will
be in our information below and this is
via their fan line and Saturday I did a
chat on live raise and the cool thing
about libraries is you can submit
questions video questions so you can
submit a question on there when I'm on
live you can submit a question it goes
to the fan line it's a video question
where you can ask whatever you want and
then we can take those questions and we
can put them onto the show so I'll be
going on next Saturday again and you'll
be able to get on there and submit video
questions and get them onto the show and
we have our first one ever and let's get
to it right here here we go you'll be
able to hear it on the audio and you'll
be able to see it on YouTube this is our
first ever live raised video question
via their fan line here we go hey Theo
longtime fan first Wow and look some of
you guys heard that voice you might
think this man is a beautiful urban
gentleman you know that beautiful
mahogany superhero it's not this boy man
he looks like Chef Boyardee 'he's kind
of grandson a little bit that you know
used to sell grams but also makes a mean
[ __ ]
ratatouille you know what I'm saying
this boy looks like he's he looks like
the real deal let's hear it let's hear
it here we go hey Theo longtime fan
first-time caller
God what did he eat Detroit man a set
dude he has so much so she has so much
sultry soul in his voice man
let's hear more I'm just wondering
what's the right amount of shrooms to
take when you go and see Joey Coco Diaz
I just saw him I dropped an eighth Wow
man I say this
Joey Coco Diaz is is a there's nothing
like him it's like getting to be in the
middle of a tornado but the tornado is
made out of joy and laughter and fun and
you know that Joey's heart is so good
that no matter what he says that it's
edgy and fun and whatever and you know
it's real to him but you know that his
heart is good so you know that he's
joking and it just hits you at a core of
what's wrong with a lot of our world
today is that everybody just goes on
what people say or there but nobody's at
all looking at where people's hearts are
at and you can tell it immediately you
could tell where people's hearts are
it's the easiest thing to tell
you know in cocoa Diaz's heart is it's
in the right spot baby I mean it's
almost like you know you know who's that
John Wilkes Booth who are something
who's that famous designer or you know
guy that does buildings who does draws
buildings Frank Lloyd Webber it's almost
like Frank Lloyd Webber designed exactly
where to put coat coat Diaz's heart so
you know everything in there is fun
because you know he's coming from a
place of good and so no matter what he
says it's fun and it's fun for everybody
and man it taking screws on it whoo I
don't know but you said bro you had fun
man you guys got to see this guy if you
look at him on the YouTube man is a
beautiful guy this guy's beautiful and
your women and their shroom DUP this
sultry gentleman right here he went in
there shroom DUP and got it done I
wouldn't take any but I'm glad you did
man I'm glad you went there that I bet
it's a beautiful way to see Diaz because
it's almost like you know when you're on
mushrooms you want to see something
natural you want to see something real
that came out of the universe you want
to see something special and Joey Diaz
is the only comedian ever I was talking
with um with your Rogen about this the
other day the only comedian ever where I
found myself found myself standing out
of my seat
cheering and laughing at the same time
like it's [ __ ] 1910 and a warship
with my dad just came back to the shore
in San Diego like you know what I'm
saying like I'd never done anything like
that in my life out of my seat cheering
what and I was doing that and I was
living like that because he has a
special gift and Joe Rogan says this a
lot it's like what is people's intention
that's what the that's what that's what
matters what is somebody's intention
because that's what's killing comedy and
the truth is I don't think things things
are killing it anymore I think you have
guys like you know you have guys who are
funny with with good hearts who are out
there fighting every day for
comedy to be based on intention and I
think that it's coming back around and
that's why I follow you know guys that I
follow and that's why I look up to guys
that I look up to because they're
they're pioneers this old [ __ ] of being
offended by everything that [ __ ] is done
bro you want to live there then you
choose to live there that's a choice if
somebody can't say this somebody people
could say whatever they want what's
their intention look you want to use a
racial slur go use it but go use it
around that race see how that works out
for you dude I grew up in the south man
you want to you want to drop an N bomb
around somebody that might have a
different skin tone than you you're
gonna learn really fast that that's not
a comfortable choice because people know
people's intention you know intention
man that's what in and that's where
that's where I'm trying to live and
that's where these guys live man so KOCO
Diaz I you know I don't care if you saw
him and you were on your last leg I
don't care if you out there you know
drink and bone marrow out of a can
because you're you know you might not
make it in any condition you see him in
that's a beautiful condition but that
1/8 boy that sounds good bro that's what
I like about the mushrooms boy you know
when I used to eat them mushrooms do you
start [ __ ] looking for yourself and
that's crazy
because you are yourself and that's man
that's a beautiful treat let's go to
another call that came in thank you guys
for calling and thank you for that live
raised fan line question you can do
those now and so it's we just want to
add another element to the YouTube where
people can see what's going on and
that's live raised you can check out
their app check them out through
Instagram and we'll have the link below
in that way on Saturday when I go live
I'll let you know what I'm doing that
I'll put it in my Instagram story you
can jump on there and submit a question
and I want to answer it then but I will
answer it on next Monday's episode here
we go
another follow-up call from last week's
episode of this past weekend yeah this
is kevin from new jersey calling about
to do to his sister 19 year olds bang in
the 39 year old dude yep we had that
call last week the gentleman called his
sister was 19 and dating a 39 year old
so my sister's 19 and her boyfriend is
39 years old onward I think for sure he
needed to beat his ass you need to put a
stop to that that definitely did Dark
Arts and the fact he's got a call to
hotline and ask for a suggestions kind
of questionable but yeah I mean yeah you
would think for most people it is
questionable
you know let's hear more Kevin anyway
that's it thank you you bet man thanks
for calling Brian that's how they handle
it over there in New Jersey that dudes
doing that
you got to tighten that ass up on that
dude 39 year old you know and he's
staying up at night and just licking the
freckles off heels I'll feel off yours
19 year old sister's neck dude I'd beat
those freckles out of that man I think I
would but then look but then look I'll
look at my own life and I'm like well
[ __ ] my mother was 32 when I was born my
father was 70 so what is that
no somebody should have brought probably
whoop somebody's asked there but then I
don't even exist you know there's
different sides to it there's different
worlds and look I don't think it was
right probably what my parents did you
know I mean I think my father was
probably looking to you know create just
more of a legacy something anything to
keep him living to feel like he was
living more and being virile as a senior
you know when you spraying out and that
spray is growing up and going to
kindergarten you know that's got to make
you feel you know voracious and you can
keep moving forward but thank you for
calling Kevin and shout out to everybody
in Jersey dude people always look down
on New Jersey for different types of
[ __ ] man [ __ ] that Jersey is the realest
bruh you can't even get real in
Manhattan anymore go get where you can't
get mugged in Manhattan go on even the
pigeons brought all the dopest pigeons
are the ones that will [ __ ] on you
they're all out in Queens now they've
been evicted all the best pigeons that
you know them carrier pigeons every now
and then you see a pigeon with a [ __ ]
grandma blow in its mouth you know one
of them little freaking short baggies
you can't even see that in Manhattan
anymore that [ __ ] so it's all this the
elites elites only that's what they
should call Manhattan you can't find a
[ __ ] regular you can't find a poor
person in Manhattan that's for this for
rich only bruh you can come visit you
know you could ride the big bus through
the middle that double-decker but if you
want to you can't get [ __ ] on by a real
bird anymore you can't even get stabbed
in Manhattan
dude when I was growing when I was the
first time I went to New York did I drop
the dildo in a damn bodega you know you
know and [ __ ] got weird after that or
whatever before that but that was that
was Manhattan you know I saw they had to
do jumped off a building back in the day
when I was there and robbed a they had a
senior citizen lady it out there with
this skirt on and she goes did you see
it and I'm like did I see the guy she
goes did you see it I'm like the I'm
like did I see what the guy jumped off
the building and then she
shade up show me that frickin that bird
holster bra this lady just showed me
your crotch out of the blue and I was
like what and that was New York that was
Manhattan now you want to get really you
better go into the boroughs you better
go in Brooklyn you that [ __ ] it's real
but is it's but it's is it you can't
find any new any Newsies out there where
the Newsies at they're all out in Queens
now Bronx Fat Joe country they're all
out and Hasbrouck Heights they're out
there they're out there in New Jersey
that's where they're at all them real
boys moving out as for the elites bruh
is it maybe I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about have you thought about
that think about that as well alright
let's get to another call here here we
go hey what's going on - yo this is Rico
here from down in California
what's up Rico out there and Downey and
I've been out there by Downey before I
ran out of gas out there one time and a
man this is this is you know where I
think it could have honestly was one of
those people at a service station you
know it could have been a man could have
been a woman they were real you know
they they had a lot of dirt and you know
come but you know small get really
heavily affected by the smog in their
hair and everything and pores so anyhow
a man or woman trying to climb in my
sunroof dude and I was finding them out
and then all they wanted was a hit of my
big goat so I [ __ ] gave uh you know
this person a hit of that big goat and
then then they gave it back to me and
then I'm like well what the [ __ ] I don't
want anymore so then I'll roll down the
window and gave it to him full and since
I think a lot of time a trick sometimes
of you know of these I guess these are
just kind of soda pop spies really cuz
they spy and they see somebody hitting a
big open they come in through the
through the sunroof and then they get
that sip and then they know you're not
gonna want the rest of it but anyhow I
got taken advantage of thank you for
calling Rico onward just listening I
wanted to call in about a hour old boy
who has a 19 year old sister [ __ ] they
that whatever 3935 girl man I tell you
what man I tell you what I got a sister
she's a bus she's almost 17 years old if
I if I found out you know she was she
was dating some guy I was 39 I call them
up amen I need to see you and we need to
have a have a face-to-face a man-to-man
conversation there you go right there
now that's a good point that's a really
good point and this makes me think to
even back to my own existence
my mother was 32 so that's different
this is a 19 year old no other was 32
making at least thirty two year old
female choices let's hear more when you
met me to have that conversation look
I'm I'm 23 years old I meet him up
I tell them a man I'm trying my best
everything in my body tells me to whip
your ass like you right now everything
in my body want to put a little Shih Tzu
on yo neck and snap that [ __ ] brother
damn boy they change it man they forget
they switching up vertebrae's dude he do
Rico's about to play Jenga with some
buddies vertebraes over there let's hear
more Patel look man you were that she's
not even out of her teens yet bro not
even out of her teens yet and you got
some [ __ ] old saggy bald really
[ __ ] body no hair cuz he's losing it
all [ __ ] holla at your little
sisters no way tell him he'd never be
welcomed into the family he'd never even
know don't tell him never to be
comfortable around me don't ever be
comfortable around me and it's got to
end and you can't control her and you
can't control him but let him know he
will never be welcome in that family in
that family Wow
there you go and I love that line that
you said do you never be comfortable
around me
oh that's a savage line right there you
know and that's a respect to a level of
respect and you know it's also showing
up in its shown respect you're not
whipping the dude's ass but you say
you're letting him know point-blank
you do not ever be comfortable around me
you know and that brings me back you
know my sister and my brother used to
live together for a little while and and
my sister dated all kind of wild cats
and and I think that doesn't our family
we've dated you know we don't date well
and and one time a man showed up and
honk the horn
you know this man my sister was dating
and boy my brother ran out there and he
told that man to get the [ __ ] out of
there he said you're gonna come and pick
my sister up for a date you're gonna
come in and you're gonna come to the
door and you're gonna knock and and that
was you know that's the kind of thing
that needs to happen that's the kind of
thing that needs to be done you know as
men we have to you know we have to
embrace our sisters and we have to hold
them up you know we have to get out of
our own lives sometimes out of what's
going on with us and hold men that they
spend time with accountable you know cuz
I mean my sister got a you know she got
really you know abused and stuff like
this by men that she dated and I don't
know I mean I don't know if I'm putting
her I'm not trying to put her story out
there anything like that maybe she'll
come home one day you know but she got
you know then this happens to a lot of
women out there butts and I didn't know
my sister then we weren't close but you
know as men we have to do that you know
sometimes we want to not get along with
our sister and that shit's fine you
cannot get along with our sister that's
what I'm learning but at the same time I
can still be a brother
I can still be a brother you know I was
talking to a friend of mine the other
day and and and he was saying that his
father wasn't good to him he goes but
just because my father wasn't good to me
doesn't mean that I couldn't be a good
son to him because I still have my own
responsibilities
because then years later I might my
father might leave the earth or whatever
and I and I'm sitting there thinking wow
he was never good to me
and also I'm thinking wow I was never
good to him
you could be like oh whoa you know he
would you weren't good to him because he
wasn't good to you but that's that's
where that's where we all [ __ ] up or
that's where I [ __ ] up anyway I'm sorry
I shouldn't have said we all because I
don't know I don't know other people's
lives but I know that's where I [ __ ] up
when I think that because somebody did
something to me then I should do it to
them
but know what I do is Who I am
and sometimes you show somebody enough
love you know you show them what's real
and they can and that's how they learn
it you think if somebody's a dick to you
you're a dick back to them they're gonna
[ __ ] learn anything else than being a
dick sure you got to be the bigger
person but that's you no no no man chess
I don't me to go [ __ ] I don't know I'm
just like I think about that [ __ ] with
with the president a lot with Trump you
know like I think I've never been a
political man
you know I think I've never trust in any
of these politics I think we have some
of the same problems and I think the
problems are us I think the problems are
humans I think is we're getting this
world right now where there's a lot of
humans that don't want to be even really
beat they're not even doing anything
we're not doing some people ain't doing
nothing and you got other people that
want to do something that want to move
that want to do stuff
and I think sometimes it's like but that
you know yeah and you have these
networks and these in these people that
just hate Donald Trump someone like what
do you teaching this man what are you
teaching him and I don't hate him you
know I don't think I think he's an
egomaniac I think all politicians are
there's no way you get into that I don't
think with heaven first of all you have
to have a big ego and that that can be
okay but that can also be extremely
[ __ ] dangerous bro the ego it's a
reminds me of that that volcano in
Hawaii that thing's always trying to
sneak live out the side you know you
think you're you know there's nothing
that scares me more than ego scares me
every day I wake up scared that my brain
is gonna trick me into thinking certain
things about myself that are not going
to be good for me but I think that about
you know it's just like how many so much
hatred like what do you win anything
with all that [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] man
you know it's just like I does anybody
really hate somebody as much as all
these news are it's just like really hey
go to [ __ ] work none of these
politicians have ever affected my life
ever ever I never even seen any of them
I don't think I thought I saw one of
them one time at the airport I don't
know who it was
homework what else man thanks for
calling Rico let's hear a little let's
take another call here this is Dalton
hey Theo it's uh it's Dalton from
Virginia wow that's a wild named Dalton
bruh I never heard of it before and
that's a risky name too if somebody
called you dolt you know because I don't
mean you know that means not super you
know keen to what's happening but
whatever bro [ __ ] yeah that's a great
name dude because now you're you
changing that [ __ ] you know that's like
you know saying my name is skimpy and
people like you skimpy you're like nah
baby I'm [ __ ] thick you're like uh oh
okay so skimpy is doing something
different with it all
let's hear more though um this has been
response to the secret the gentleman who
wrote in I'm a 31 year old secret at the
time I was conceived my gay mother was
doing coke with my birth father she
wanted a kid he was married with kids
already but my mother promised him that
I'd be kept a secret 31 years later
still a secret would you seek these
people out if you were me but on to that
I just want to share a little quick
personal thing that happened part of my
family not real close to my family I
just know the story my dad's brother
married kids married 20 30 some years
several three four kids one day got a
knock at the door and it was a lady
about 28 years old I was like you know I
think you might be my father
and so I showed up out of nowhere they
sat down and kind of went through the
timeline and you know sure enough you've
been traveling at some point you know I
were 28 some years ago and had gotten a
lady pregnant over I guess in Japan or
something like that
damn that's wild man and look I'd be
honest it would be hard to go to Japan
and probably not trying to bust a nut
somewhere think about that I mean you
know I remember being young and I was
traveling around a good bit and and I
would want to bust nuts on all these
continents you know and I remember one
night falling asleep thinking I'm a bust
I'm a bust a nut on all 40 40 [ __ ]
continents and then I get up in the
morning and there's only seven
continents or nine and I'm like wow
where was I was just gonna be jerking
off in like 31 other places for no
reason you know I mean that would've
been crazy you know you're out in [ __ ]
Guam beating off and people like what
are you doing you know like I'm settling
this land yeah I got a score to settle
with her so but that you know that's
that's uh that's something impressive
man that's something impressive you know
that she just showed up that had to be a
long [ __ ] lunch boy what if your dad
had just settled down to a sandwich he
made himself his favorite sandwich the
game is on his [ __ ] favorite game and
then he gets a doorbell ring he opens it
and it's somebody that in his eyes and
soeul he knows immediately man I know
her from somewhere
even if he's never met her and bam bruh
you got a bonus child that's crazy
that's crazy you know I had a girl reach
out to me on Facebook a few years ago
two years ago she said that we could be
half siblings and we talked on the phone
once and I might try to look her back up
and I've never met her and maybe she
would actually come on here be a neat
guest to have that would be a super neat
guest but uh Dalton was here a little
bit more here we go you know our 28 some
years ago and had gotten a lady pregnant
over I guess in Japan or something like
that but it messed things up for a
little bit before a little weird for
maybe a day or two but that's not that
long if you think about it and she's a
great part of the family now I know they
have her over all the time her she has a
sea of clear two that they treat you
know just like one of the grain grain
ships from the beginning you know it's a
fantastic thing now and it looks a
little a little bit different of a
situation but maybe that experience
helps you guys out I get it out I guess
you really just never know until you do
something about it yeah that's a great
point man look and people I think yeah
there's that hiccup in the beginning
user with most things but then most
people want to love
most people want other people in their
life yeah you know I think about
sometimes I would give anything to have
uh like a little like a brother or a
sister that was really young you know
like a nine year old so you know what
though that was a nine year old right
now just to see them be alive and just
for me to have that experience and watch
them be a human and become a human and
you know I see it some of my nieces and
nephews and that's fine but it would be
really neat to have it as like a brother
or a sister you know a younger child
where where I could be a sibling to them
in some facet you know in a part of
their life in some way man that would be
you know there's just such a blessing I
think and having children and creating
that thing you know you don't even
realize I think it when you create a
family you don't even realize probably a
lot of the gifts that you you're gonna
create moments that those siblings are
gonna have between each other that you
you can't even fathom you only you won't
even be there to wit
but there'll be beautiful moments and
that's awesome that you know somebody
showed up at the door that's that long
knock and you think it's a pizza
delivery and damn that's that DNA
delivery you know is that uh that's
DNA's your no bruh that's at the door
bro that's forever in this family bruh
you got an extra-large trade-off family
dude gang bruh wear them two litre colas
that remember that they used to get you
on that [ __ ] Pizza Hut no Domino's you
be like we got that 2-liter soda Brian
remember this one dude one time was we
ordered a bunch of pizza to this party
and he came out he'd been drinking
delivering pizzas and he started off the
road because the road was [ __ ] super
dangerous it wasn't even a road it was
just like a place where people would
drive try to drive down it and basically
just mostly almost died and sometimes
really died
and he [ __ ] this dude slipped off
into the woods next thing you know he's
at the door and he's bleeding and stuff
like that and a couple people kept
talking him at the front door and
calling 9-1-1 and stuff and then some
other people winter went around to his
car and got the pizzas out he had like
nine pizzas cuz this dude was you know
back in the day you would leave once and
you would just you might be out there
delivering for four hours and and and he
all sweated once a two liter sodas that
were just spraying everywhere because
they'd been in the car accident and so
they were spraying everywhere so that's
one thing that was kind of a beautiful
treat about them sodas is that you could
shake them up and you had a little party
right there and you could spray half of
it and drink half of it and that's kind
of nice
let's hear another call here we go heo
salad
kentucky i just calling to comment on
the guy who wrote in last week saying
that he was a secret and i want him to
know that he and alone out there that I
myself was also a secret my mother and
the guy hooked up whenever they were
young had me and then they got you know
I said they were just kids the guy
coming ran away or whatever she moved
back to Kentucky um with me and met it
with my who I always thought was my dad
my real dad I had a little set
sir it was five years younger than me I
never thought anything other until I got
aged about thirteen and of course
small-town gossip the man who raised me
wasn't my real father Wow and that's a
wild rumor to hear around town because
you you know I remember hearing [ __ ]
like you know there's a man that sleeps
you know outdoors at night without a
tent and I remember hearing [ __ ] that
you know somebody was crossbreeding
animals and you would hear stuff like
you know you know there's a woman that
had they had a woman that kept um like a
rare coin she had a wig and she would
keep a rare coin under it and so we
would always be plotting on ways to like
you know get that wig off and you know
get that treasure but to hear that you
know that you've got a different family
that's a unique rumor let's hear more
and then right at about that same time
he passed away right to sue my throat
and died damn semi that's a sad man that
semi-truck brother those things are
[ __ ] dangerous you get hit by that
[ __ ] or anything man you [ __ ] up and
they're square in the front you know
mozell someone remember the old ones
were just straight up squaring you have
a nose on them what the [ __ ] man but I'm
sorry to hear that bud and I'm sorry to
hear that
I finally reached out I have three
sisters other than the one I was raised
with and two brothers and I'm the oldest
of all of them they're great people
Tommy went up there he met them got to
hang out with something everything I
never met the dad or whatever my ex's
name yeah man yeah man well look there
you go
you never know you never know when you
know and that's a gift it's a gift so
your family gets bigger and your heart
gets bigger and it's a little more
unique it's the same thing that with
thinking it's the same thing when you
know you had an eight box and now you
got that 64 hit or somebody showed up
and you got [ __ ] new family you got
new senior citizens they got pets you
know look at little Marco the [ __ ]
chicken eats us you know you got it all
and everything changes and that's it man
sometimes we just we what we get so
stuck we don't want to change
and that's one thing man I swear to god
dude I've been thinking about the past
couple days I'd never thought you know
just even just going on the Joe Rogan's
podcast and thinking about and I'm not
trying to keep name dropping that I'm
just it shook me you know I'll just woke
up the next day thinking wow what if
there's different universes and what if
you met yourself would you like yourself
and just my mind was a little more open
and your hearts a little more open when
you get that kind of thing when you get
that new family member thank you for
calling him and let's hear a little
let's hear this dude alright we got this
right in that came in and this is a text
that came into the hotline hey Theo my
name is Zach from Houston shout out
h-town I'm 20 I'm texting from the
hotline because I'm having brain surgery
on Monday the 21st I probably should
have said procedure because surgery
sounds aggressive but it's not major
brain surgery they ain't cracking my
skull open or anything they're going
through my artery to shoot some glue to
make this thing stop growing damn I
don't know what's growing in your head
bro but you know if fitting ideas or
hope then it's probably pretty painful
and I'm sorry to hear that dude you know
and I appreciate you telling me about
this I don't understand it but the
doctors do so I'm gonna trust them
that's huge
that's huge to trust others that's big
man that's a huge in a very adult move
man you say you're 20 that's a very
adult move too because you sitting there
just so scared and concerned and because
you don't trust them that's the decade
that I can only imagine how painful that
would be and so if you to put trust into
them that's very huge man I'm gonna
trust them the thing is I'm nervous
about us forgetting things or having a
stroke which could happen it's rare but
it happens I'm not afraid to die so I
kind of hope I die instead of have a
stroke or be disabled man that's brave
of you dude you know and I you know yeah
sometimes yeah cuz look you might come
right back God might need you right back
you know right back Zach you might be
that dude right back Zach that you live
for 20 years and you pop right back and
they need you somewhere else we need
Zach over here we need
in Wisconsin we need him in Houston
again you know we needs Atkins I hear
like people like damn Saxons are year
you know you might have that might be
for you that might be God's plan for you
bro or the higher powers plan for you
whatever you want to think whatever you
want to call it that's fine people gets
Curtis Curtis on the god thing that's
that's the three letters baby that's
just the quickest way to say you know
what I'm saying it's something else out
there pushing the pieces play in the
chessboard but yeah man let me read a
little bit more so in case I forget
something I can read this and jog my
memory
you really funny keep up the podcast and
stand up and hope that show gets picked
up on Comedy Central man that's so nice
you dude you know here you are you know
and he sent this this came in yesterday
and here you are you know you might be
on your way out
are you thinking about me man thank you
you know when you're thinking about us
you're not just not any thinking about a
lot of people but you know you wanted to
say you're funny and keep up the podcast
and stand up and I will man and look and
I'll be looking out for you if you go to
heaven man will be looking out for you
on the flip side
that's right back exact and if you don't
go that when I come to Houston man come
out and be my guest please and and look
I might make you laughs armed you might
have a stroke then bro how crazy would
that be dude oh this is so [ __ ] up I
shouldn't be thinking about this but we
love you bro thanks for reaching out
dude you have a lot of people thinking
about you're gonna be okay you're gonna
be okay either way you're gonna be okay
either way man you sound like you got a
huge heart okay and all these calls come
out of the hotline and that's nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
anybody can hit the hotline with
responses suggestions for people or
issues that you're dealing with if
there's anything you're trying to you
know you're struggling with you know or
anything you want to think about but
yeah if there's something you're
struggling with man you got something in
your heart you got something your
feelings man get it out there you know
don't keep that inside of you by
yourself you know because that's what's
[ __ ] us is that we just afraid to feel
man we're afraid to be vulnerable and I
am too you know when we do it here
together
so let's take this next hit here bang
hey do you know a longtime listener
first-time caller here I heard you say
on the Joe Rogan podcast that where you
lived in Louisiana there was a lot of
magic mushrooms growing naturally oh
yeah boy oh yeah I was just wondering if
you could you know maybe follow up on
that how do you identify those mushrooms
is there like a taste process where
maybe it's not like a civil Simon
mushroom so maybe you eat a little bit
of [ __ ] on accident to try and test it
so you'll get those effects damn brother
it's not like you calling like a 1 900
number like this is like some kind of
sex line or something for about about
mushrooms like you want me to just like
oh yeah baby so what happened was I
would take my shoes off you see and run
out into there into that damp grass and
right there on the soil you'd see a big
old areola of cow dung man that thing
was shining and glistening and right off
the top of it you would see a beautiful
mihika more animal and that is latino
brother for magic mushroom you know I'm
saying that David Copperfield that's
gonna give you them floppy feels bruh
man you had the magic mushrooms Judah
what do you mean I mean out there eating
[ __ ] brah
this ain't a Japanese game show daddy
this was young bucks out there and dude
it looks like a magic mushroom google
that [ __ ] for you just run around a
field with your mouth open
cuz 96.7% of mushrooms are killers okay
that's why when you get that special 3%
it's magic if you just get in them
killers and you snacking on killers
you're gonna fall apart so get out there
and get that hit erm and get the real
thing and it's beautiful white stem and
it's so just succulent
look I mean it looks like somebody just
poured a tall glass of milk
that's how white the stem is and then
it's got this dirty little skirt but the
skirt doesn't even go down it just goes
straight out on the side around the stem
it's just this beautiful little purple
skirt and that's where the [ __ ] magic
is boy and that's where you feel the
[ __ ] Lord just just licking the back
of your neck when you get those headers
brewing out there eating [ __ ] do you be
a wild boy he being wild but thank you
for calling man thank you for calling
you what that was yeah and then we put
on many more mouths and everything
changed and the world just started and
just the clouds just started dripping
out of the sky and we were catching the
drops in our mouths and spitting them
onto each other's backs what you want to
hear man what do you want to hear okay
let's let's take another caller - here
we go hey what's up Co this is Jesse I
live out here in Silver Lake
I'm a storyboard artist on Bob's Burgers
so I was at a LA Fitness a couple weeks
back got in there pretty early before
where it started
get in there more so I was finishing up
my workout and I go and get in the
shower and Amy took a shower - LA
Fitness dude man that's that's hectic
maybe more they have those soap
dispensers that are up on the wall about
4 feet or so off the ground and they're
clear so you can see inside - the soap
and and what was in the dude semen I go
and put my hand up underneath it and I'm
about to get a couple couple squirts and
why they're up him dude you might want
to talk to the mushroom dude I feel like
both you guys trying to meet each other
more and I see something in there so I
look a little closer and lo and behold
there is a 14-inch fully intact turd mmm
oh wow I didn't expect that man somebody
put a turd in the straight-up hand soap
dispenser oh that is archaic move bro
that's old-school man that's back in the
I mean that's like something you would
do like that's like that old Trojan
horse bro you think you're getting soap
and then but damn boy that's just you
got that you know you got that feces uh
you you know you think you're getting
you think you're getting soap and then
BAM boy you got them fecal paws bruh and
that's just um that's pinkeye waiting to
happen that's pinkeye country you're
flirting with more sitting and it was
pretty shocking I didn't put the soap on
my body you lie bruh you are lying
and look I Love You Man I appreciate you
calling Jesse but you have to say that
you can't sit here and tell us the truth
man do we know what happened there's no
way you loo you went the first time and
then put it off it's the second time you
went back when you saw that [ __ ]
hitter when you saw some dude drop that
booty hitter into that soap dispenser my
god I've never heard of this but where
is the FBI where's the FDA more I went
out there told the maintenance man that
there is [ __ ] in the soap dispenser he
basically stopped me mid-sentence and
told me that it's been happening often
and that they have a serial [ __ ] so
figured either run that one by you as if
you've ever come across and he's dumped
in any weird locations or taking it down
to yourself oh that's a good question
man have you ever taken a dump yourself
in a weird locale well you a lot of
people know this you know I used to talk
about this or I've told this story when
I was growing up they had a boy in my
neighborhood and he you know named Mario
and he was Italian bro or he said he was
anyway or his parents just
he wasn't named a Mario and he was even
named I remember after Super Mario I
think the video game so that's [ __ ]
that's bizarre but anyhow he uh he would
you know make poops in his yard and make
me bury him so I could hang out with him
because he that was the only way he let
me hang out with him if he if when he
did feces in the yard I had to you know
I had this little shovel little beach
shovel and little pail and I had to bury
him in there for him and so I did it you
know I didn't know any better I was a
child and I had you know I had a uh I
was just I was wearing over all my
mother always had me in overalls and
[ __ ] so I looked probably you know in
these little like um what are those
hippie kind of sandals not happy but
they're like [ __ ] I don't know man
they're like these they're leather and
they look like you know they look like
almost like indentured servants would
wear them they are Cumberland or
something Hilbert um some sandals [ __ ] I
don't know the [ __ ] sandals bruh and
then so I would wear these wild little
sandals with these overalls I'll
probably look like I should be burying
[ __ ] so that if somebody drove by and
saw me out there you know hiding these
[ __ ] little body bats they weren't
thinking that I was about you know they
probably like oh yeah you dressed like
that you deserve to be [ __ ] Berrien
dukes and this kid Mariel would mean
Barry all his shits were on this dude
and so it got repetitive he was [ __ ]
all the time so I've never had anything
like that I never had anybody pooping a
soap dispenser but I have had people you
know [ __ ] for fun and different places
and um and you know I was kind of you
know how to I guess a service commitment
you know at that boys yard but then
years later he died he drove us bass
boat into an embankment on you know
allegedly on drugs and you know rest in
peace and I actually wrote his parents a
letter and told him about that you know
and told them what had happened back in
the day and and I miss you know uh and
he was of he was a wild boy he had the
wild in the cinema you know sometimes he
had something extra
known in him he was he just had like a
special energy you know he had a special
energy and uh and and he and he was into
some of the Dark Arts I think and he but
anyhow they buried him I'm guessing and
they didn't let me be a pallbearer and
that kind of pissed me off you know and
a little bit somewhere in my head I had
a resentment because I'm like man these
people [ __ ] put that boy in the
ground and they didn't let me do it
because nobody's put more of that boy in
the ground than this boy right here
you know and God rest his soul man but
uh yeah sorry that that's happening dude
there's people [ __ ] in soap
dispensers dude
that's what happens bro that's what
happens when you don't trust the
government anymore you know that's what
happens when they when the Democratic
Party railroads their own candidates
that's what happens when a 70 year old
man Bernie Sanders who gave his whole
life to politics gets [ __ ] out of his
own [ __ ] nomination that's what
happens in this world bro
onward let's hear more CEO gone normally
great job on the Joe Rogan podcast it
yeah world wedding was the other was
today was this morning early this
morning late I'm getting out of work I'm
a bartender in Santa Monica you can come
anytime you're on local sober like you
but if our time cuz they make money
thanks for calling in no yeah the royal
wedding was this weekend more um listen
about the royal wedding it's a big deal
my wife was telling me all about you got
the black girls you half white half
black you know she's going to be in the
royal family it's a big deal she's
American it's all these first time for
everything but I want to say like you
really want to be different and your
Prince Harry who looks like a ginger
marry another ginger like I got a buddy
he's black guy he's in all these
commercials with a white wife and the
mixed kid the mix came to make thing is
like that's in right now if you really
want to be like a trailblazer your right
and your agenda there yeah that's
another agenda keep the gingers going
that's what I'm saying man that's true
keep the gingers going dude that's a
great point yeah it's like you want to
be wild be do something that's out of
the norm that's not being seen
you know marry somebody of your own of
your own style even I'm not saying that
don't merit don't interracial Marilyn
any of that but I'd love to see a big
sister and a Japanese boy where's that
at
you know I'd love to see a UH a
blond-haired blue-eyed gal and a thick
and a and a rubenesque Korean fella you
know I'd love to see that mix but I'd
also like to see that ginger on ginger
would they even allow that if you saw
two gingers kissing at a stoplight would
you call the cops
yeah it's like I agree it's like you
know we want different always changes
what's different always changes and yeah
now it's like you see so many
commercials where the family is also
mixed and I think it's good for
advertising because you want everybody
to feel you know you want everybody to
feel you know you don't want a kid to
watch a Disney World commercial or
Disneyland commercial I've talked about
this before and see only white people at
Disneyland or only what you know certain
types of people are only wealthy people
at Disneyland are only Asian people at
SeaWorld are only you know black people
at you know we're you know trying to
think of our essence fast you know you
want to see you want everybody to feel
welcome especially via advertising but
yeah you want to do something while do
something do something really brave you
know I'm saying you only got one I marry
somebody with only with two eyes or you
got two eyes marry somebody with [ __ ]
three eyes or half a dick
you know do something different you're
not gay marry somebody with a dick
that's different
do some unique stuff yeah because yes
sometime the same old stuff is the same
old stuff make that you got a you got
eight bucks
let's get that sixty-four you know I'm
saying somebody got one titty [ __ ]
find somebody that's magenta let's make
a real wild family but ginger and ginger
do would they even allow it
these are the questions we're asking man
these are the hard hitters haha what
else man I feel like man I feel like
we've done a pretty good job this week
man okay yep all right we're gonna take
one more question here here we go
hey there's Rob and Georgia man what's
up Rob and Georgia thank you for calling
man beautiful state you have there I'm
just listening to this Nicole Arbour
podcast is all it excited to see a new
episode up anyway
I'm only 20 minutes in and I can't help
but notice you seem kind of hostile man
were you having a bad day when you
interviewed her you genuinely not like
this woman I just want to get your
thoughts on that wonder why you were
feeling like that
thanks for calling Rob um you know it
was interesting having Nicole Arbour in
I think she's a funny lady I think she's
an entertainer I think you know I'm not
not gonna have somebody on the podcast
because you know there's this general
thing in the air where people don't like
them you know I mean I would I have
Satan on ya cuz you know why I got to
question for Satan you know you think
I'm sitting around with zero questions
for Satan you're wrong and I'm not
comparing the cult of Satan or either I
look I think Nicole's a tractive you
know I think that she's funny I just
didn't the thing was man honestly and
this took me an extra day or two to
think about and this is the last that
I'll talk about this is that I didn't I
don't know if she's genuine and that's
what I didn't that's that's what made me
feel uncomfortable I don't I don't
believe that she is genuine and I could
be wrong and I'm happy to be wrong but I
just don't I didn't feel it and it made
I felt uncomfortable and so it was tough
you know it was tough and yeah I try to
make it an interesting conversation but
you know I feel like she's constantly
kind of in this PR world and I don't
like that world that much you know I
like something that's really real if I
can get real and some days is hard man
sometimes we don't [ __ ] feel real you
know but those times we can if we
and if we can be if we you know those
are special times these days I feel like
that but yeah I have that on that man
man so yeah we've had a lot of great
calls I appreciate that call we've had a
lot of great ones this week and I dis
appreciate you guys be at this pian just
being in here with me
you know and just help me you know I'm
just happy to be here and I'm happy that
you're here and yeah we got some cool
dates coming up on the road you know I'm
gonna try to keep my brain thinking this
week I'm I try to not stay in my small
cage sometimes you know I'm gonna try to
maybe think you know if I talk to
somebody that I don't know if I agree
with or if it's only gonna help me it's
only gonna help me but if I stay too
close to my template in my brain then
that's you can be kind of limited you
know you can be kind of limited you're
gonna be limited to your yard you're
gonna be in your fishbowl sometime you
got a [ __ ] hop out and land in
another tank and that's okay because you
can always get back into your bowl you
know but that's one of the things that I
took away from being on on Joe's show
and that's one of uh you know and I and
everything you know and he makes me feel
welcome and and I'm and you're welcome
you anybody is welcome here anybody is
welcome here and if we can't figure out
why you're not man less we'll figure it
out you know we're here to [ __ ]
figure [ __ ] out you think I'm gonna
[ __ ] live on this ball of dirt in the
middle of nowhere and not try and figure
some of this [ __ ] out not anymore I'm
not thank you guys for being here with
me man okay we're gonna close out here
and this is called this was sent in
through Theo von comm where you can send
in you can be a part of the podcast
merchandise all kinds of stuff and this
is by Thomas Siple and this is called
Gentilly Philly and thank you guys for
being here with me and you guys be good
yourselves you probably deserve it
[Music]
man is good huh
thank you Tom's a lot of talent out in
this world isn't there we're gonna be
okay you know that guy's right we got
this
[Music]